[Music]
and mind control news old from my
monitor you submitted by Jamie Z a
mind-reading device allows humans to
control Turtles using their thoughts the
moment I've been waiting for our way you
want to control animals with your mind
turtles turtles with your mind through
the joke tears like isn't that against
what you believe old Japanese medicine
so researchers from Korea
will from the Korea advanced Institute
of Science and Technology ok also take
credit for so they have developed a
device that allows them to control the
movement of a turtle users from what
thank you people on that next level k310
Andrew did you know be dope if it's like
a turtle GoPro so then you can close
your eyes and then you have your turtle
you got it yep and then you just wear
your go into the turtle brain and then
know what you're thinking sea turtle I'm
thinking a regular turtle like a
red-eared slider so you're going to be
some Chinese guys dinner that GoPro be
terrible oh [ __ ]
ha ha gonna see through so this turtle
it actually walked on land - so you got
videos I don't have video I don't have
video but from what I've read like they
had Turtles I was able to like walk over
like shallow water entry you know what
though what kind of turtles can make a
turtle do what you want to do with this
machine so turtles they're drawn to life
so they would usually move into the
direction of where the light is and so
what this institute is that they
actually created this device that can
block that light and so hey hmm making
them go against their instinct and then
they're going to die well see with with
your with your human control with your
like mind control you can actually tell
this device that's blocking the light
for the turtle to open up for the light
and to close the light until I have them
have the turtle go into either right
left or either like in dosha reticent
there anything on this hurt oh yeah so
like on the turtle you'll have like a
battery and then there's a there's like
a little camera so that you can see what
the turtle is being and then if you want
if there's like a direction you want the
turtle to go to like this device will
actually block the light in a certain
way so that the turtle will only going
up Oh controlling the turtle per say
your mind controlling this device
yes that tricks the turn and you can
only make the turtle go through
direction yes got your left right over
left
Yeah right see that's a little bit
misleading a little bit miss cuz I
thought you could tell the truth you
don't take [ __ ] I know I know that's
[ __ ] I was thinking of having an
army of turtles that can combine forces
and I can just chill like this and then
they tear me everywhere and then I just
think mmm front back side to side feet
turtles man is so majestic how do they
block the light I'm not exactly sure
what they used to block the light but is
what from whatever in the articles like
they have this device that does it watch
it and then it opens and it closes
blinds window blinds this is amazing
invention where were you pulled a string
and it just goes up and then when you
cut it this way you go down
Agatha's like nothing in front of the
turtle's head it's only on a shelf carry
on son how many bees it sounds like a
infrared light or something like in the
front that only the turtle can see and
so it shuts that off and then the turtle
is trying to follow the UV or infrared
light or whatever so so from what I've
read is just a passive device on the
turtle's back that can block the light
that that they use to guide them in time
you guys because like in the direction
that they go to they usually follow the
light imagine it's just sunglasses that
go on them and it's blue I think it's a
lot more simpler than we think I did
yeah
you guys eaten turtle no I've never even
ate I got it
you know the the nate- Islanders used to
eat their doll yeah the Hawaiian island
earth yeah they used to eat a turtle or
they were endangered in [ __ ] yeah now
you remember Julia toluse I heard
grandma cooked through turtle yeah
that's right it's [ __ ] funny dude
yeah we're at 99 Ranch and they used to
have those big pits where you see is
like those turtles I just crawling over
each other we bought like three oka and
also cool we have pets now and then the
next day and when you thought they were
pets yeah so then the next day I want to
go check up on them like I just like see
how my turtle friends are doing and then
my grandma called me in to drink some
soup and I drank in and I saw like a fin
in it and my boys dad was like what's
the turtle and I was like no you're
crying yeah I look sad and then my mom's
like stop being a little [ __ ] just
drink the soup and I'll been in it good
like the buzz good why did you keep
eating after you realize does your pet I
had a hard time by him eating meat
though I just drink the soup you're like
oh not this one but I bought the bone
you flavor the broth but I can't eat you
yeah oh man my mom's my mom go to me cuz
you lay your grandma meat assume you
have to drink I'm like pretty excited
that's the difference of [ __ ] Asian
parenting where they force your has to
eat that [ __ ] head they force you to
eat a fat dude so crazy when the point
of this invention so potentially
potentially we can use this type of
technology for military rescue or like
surveillance mission like buying a
[ __ ] turtle comes to rescue you
that's so cool this is just the 2017
version of the carrot in front of the
[ __ ] donkey just exactly what I was
thinking that's the only [ __ ] Dylan no
I don't know it's something human that's
controlling like do they have to get
wires and [ __ ] in their brain on so for
what I know like they wear this
over their head all they got to do is
write less more than like oh I'm gonna
think right that's pretty cool though
that it could happen - you're hot it's
kind of cool that this is like the
beginning stages I used to be or more we
kind of caught the tail end of it verse
about the turtles gonna be a breakdance
in this [ __ ] you know what that would be
cool though it's like imagine you got
caught by some terrorists and [ __ ] and
then like you're like in a prison in the
Middle East or whatever and then this
turtle [ __ ] cross to your rescue the
word it's the slowest [ __ ] and then you
get gets caught you never get six like
this
I want to befriend a crocodile yeah but
another purpose for this is the pot like
the possibility of advancing virtual
reality oh that's awesome dude I can't
wait till [ __ ] VR is so realistic you
don't because you know we work so much
all we need to do set up some fans see
water maybe in buckets around us close
your eyes in the round and you can every
place they stop - this place is just to
help out a little bit so you know what
it means I could take a little break
yeah because we can we can basically be
are someone's life so imagine in the
future right like someone goes like I
could be like hey guys you want to live
as me by my VR kit huh yeah or whatever
and then you put it on oh I'm gonna go
check out what Kalani is doing in Hawaii
whoo and then you become Kalani in
Hawaii you're surfing or something like
that or she's having sex this is for
yeah she's [ __ ] like a tourist I got
it I don't want to that's not me
they come at you yeah well then you
could be like what is John doing in
Alaska and you turn it on you're like
who is so cold so you could live the
lives of other people or it's like don't
see the beauty in the Beast movie now
okay well [ __ ] it let's continue well
there was a book in booty and the Beast
and booty the poem yeah I guess so
booty and the Beast so this book
basically took you anywhere that you
want because the enchantress locked them
in a castle so she gave him that too
kind of like torment in the little
business you can go to in your mind
I am a decent gold especially I want to
go to fact thank you both and the book
will take in the French oh you're not
actually there those pretty my babes in
France you need to be alright Paris
Paris
wouldn't it be cool though you could go
anywhere you want you don't have to be
that rich you could live the lives of so
many different people I kind of do that
already on Google Maps Street View
I like throughout the world doing that
that's the saddest thing I've ever heard
I know on really fun is [ __ ] Sandra's
pyramids looked like Egypt French just
gonna block a chief yeah it's important
a line
oh that would make me stand aside
cheating I got this little um so it's
kind of like what is that a kaleidoscope
or whatever you know remember those
things where you go like this and you
can go for and it's like a slideshow oh
you know what I call down high something
like that oh yeah
do you find it so there's this new thing
right I got this for my niece you put
your cell phone inside and then you put
in a yeah yeah you you you download this
app and then you can be like in France
where the Eiffel Tower is and you just
look around it is 360 view you can look
down there's [ __ ] pigeons too right
in here yeah no but this is even better
than that that's a freaking that's like
Samsung biggest like sell the VR yeah
cuz even it's pretty cool
you could go at different cities and
then you can travel forward backward I
was in Athens I went to check out like
the [ __ ] Colosseum or whatever not
the Colosseum the the poet the POTUS
potassium's Poseidon's place I don't
know what the [ __ ] it was does it does
it place down to so that you're actually
I don't know but I don't remember the
sound all I remember was like oh I'm a
walk up you go up you go down you can go
all over it
well Jay can use patience I hope you
guys liked that video once again
remember if you want to be involved just
submit some article them I'll suck your
dick now but seriously though there's
more videos up there
[Music]